[Applaudissements]
les chiliens ont le choix entre
j'approuve où je rejette le projet de
nouvelle constitution les partisans des
deux camps dû mettre un terme à leurs
campagnes 48 heures avant le vote de
dimanche
à la suite des violentes manifestations
de 2019 les chiliens ont voté à 78 % en
faveur d'une nouvelle constitution
quel que soit le résultat ce référendum
est historique c'est très très important
parce que c'est la façon disant qu' on a
trouvé on peut dire pour terminer avec
la transition ce n'est je pense qu'il ya
un accord la transition démocratique
après la dictature de pinochet qui a
terminé en
1990 une convention est lui a rédigé un
projet qui compte près de 400 articles
et un vaste programme trop vaste peut
être est trop audacieux pour une société
en grande partie conservatrice les
partisans du oui apprécié le catalogue
de droits sociaux du projet en matière
de santé d'éducation droits civiques à
l'avortement respect des minorités des
différences
les opposants rejettent les réformes des
systèmes politiques et judiciaires qui
affaiblirait l'indépendance des
institutions surtout ils sont contre la
notion de plurinationalité
qu'ils reconnaîtraient les peuples
autochtones en tant que nation dans la
nation cela vise la communauté mapuche
du sud du chili qui compte pour 13% de
la population et revendique non sans
violence parfois ces territoires
ancestraux le pays est profondément
divisé mais les sondages plongent pour
l'instant vers le rejet
exceptionnellement le vote est
obligatoire ce qui rend les prévisions
moins certaine car sur les 15 millions
de lecteurs une bonne partie d'entre eux
se seraient abstenus
le président gabriel boric s'est fait
élire en promettant de faire adopter la
nouvelle constitution qu'il a fait
imprimer 1 900 mille exemplaires pour
que les gens votent selon lui en
connaissance de cause un pari risqué
pour ce jeune président devenu assez
impopulaire mais ça a été justement ça
les problèmes du gouvernement parce que
il a uni disons sans gouvernement a
approuvé la constitution alors si la
constitution la proposition est rejetée
ça veut dire que
ça va être en lien avec l'évaluation de
son gouvernement ont porté en cas de
rejet ont craint un retour de
manifestations dans un pays pour la
risée tendu qui redoutent de plus en
plus la violence et l'insécurité
jean michel leprince sera du canada à
montréal